your research at Columbia is in part
focused on what you call cool worlds or
worlds outside our solar system where
temperature is sufficiently cool to
allow for moons rings and Life to form
and for us humans to observe it so can
you tell me more about this idea this
place of cool worlds yeah the history of
discovering planets outside our solar
system was really dominated by these hot
planets and that's just because of the
fact they're easier to find when the
very first methods came online these
were primarily the Doppler spectroscopy
method looking for wobbling stars and
also the transit method and these two
both have a really strong bias towards
finding these hot planets now
hot plants are interesting the chemistry
in their atmosphere is fascinating it's
very alien
um an example of one that's particularly
close to my heart is trace2b whose
atmosphere is so dark it's less
reflective than coal and so they have
really bizarre photometric properties
yet at the same time they resemble
nothing like our own home
and so I said there's two types of
astrophysicists the astrophysicists who
care about how the universe works they
want to understand the mechanics of the
Machinery of this universe why did the
big bang happen why is the universe
expanding how are galaxies formed and
there's another type of astrophysicist
which perhaps
um
speaks to me a little bit more it
Whispers into your ear and that is why
are we here are we alone are there
others out there and ultimately among
this journey the hot plants aren't going
to get us there we when we're looking
for life in the universe seems to make
perfect sense that there should be
plants like our own out there maybe even
moons like our own planet around gas
giants that could be habitable and so my
research has been driven by trying to
find these more draculous globes that
might resemble our own planet
so they're the ones that lurk more in
the shadows in terms of how difficult it
is to detect that much harder they're
harder for several reasons the method we
primarily use is the transit method so
this is really eclipses as the planet
passes in front of the star it blocks
out some Starlight the problem with that
is that not all planets pass in front of
their star they have to be aligned
correctly from your line of sight and so
the further away the planet is from the
Star the cooler it is the less likely it
is that you're going to get that
geometric alignment so whereas a hot
Jupiter about one percent of hot
Jupiters will transit in front of their
star only about uh 0.5 percent maybe
even a quarter of a percent of
earth-like planets will have the right
geometry to Transit and so that makes it
much much harder for us what's the
connection between temperature of the
plan and geometric alignment the
probability of geometrical element
there's not a direct connection but
they're connected varying intermediate
parameter which is their separation from
the Star so the planet will be cool if
it's further away from the Star which in
turn means the probability of getting
that alignment correct is going to be
less on top of that they also Transit
their star less frequently so if you go
to the telescope and you want to
discover how Jupiter you could probably
do it in a week or so because the
orbital periods of order of one two
three days so you can actually get the
full orbit two or three times over
whereas if you want to touch an
Earth-like planet you have to observe
that star for three four years and
that's actually one of the problems with
Kepler Kepler was this very successful
mission that NASA launched
um over a decade ago now I think and it
discovered thousands of planets it's
still the dominant source of exoplanets
that we know about but unfortunately it
didn't last as long as we would have
liked it to it died after about 4.35
years I think it was and so for an
Earth-like planet that's just enough to
catch four transits and four transits
was kind of seen as the minimum but of
course the more transits you see the
easier it is to detect it because you
build up signal to noise if you see the
same thing the more ticks you get the
easier is to find it and so it was
really a shame that Kepler was just at
the limit of where we were expecting it
to start to see earth-ite planets and in
fact it really found zero zero planets
that are around stars like the sun
they're all bits similar to the Earth
around the Sun and could potentially be
similar to our own planet in terms of
its composition and so it's a great
shame but um that's why it gives
astronomers more to do in the future
just to clarify the transit method
is our primary way of detecting these
things
and what it is is uh
when the object passes occludes the
source of light just a tiny bit a few
pixels and from that we can infer
something about its mass and size and
distance geometry all of that that's
like trying to tell
what uh
uh at a party you can't see anything
about a a person but you can just see by
the way they occlude others so this is
the method but is this is super far away
how many pixels of information do we
have
basically how high resolution is the
signal that we
um that we can get about these
occlusions
you're right in your description I think
just to build upon that a little bit
more it might be almost like your vision
is completely blurry like you have an
extreme you know High prescription and
so you can't resolve anything
everything's just blurs and but you can
tell that something was there because it
just got fainter for a short amount of
time something someone passed in front
of a light yeah and so that light in
your eyes would just dim for a short
moment now the reason we have that
problem with blowness or resolution is
just because the stars are so far away I
mean these are the closest stars of four
light years away but most of the Stars
Kappa looked at were thousands of light
years away
and so you there's absolutely no chance
that the telescope can physically
resolve
the star or even the separation between
the planet and the star is or is too
small especially for a tasker like
Kepler it's only a meter across in
principle you can make those detections
but
you need a different kind of telescope
we call that direct Imaging and direct
Imaging is a very exciting distinct way
of detecting planets but it as you can
imagine is going to be far easier to
detect plants which are really far away
from their star to do that because
that's going to make that separation
really big and then you also want the
star to be really close to us so the
nearest Stars not only that but you
would prefer that planet to be really
hot because the hotter it is the
brighter it is and so that tends to bias
direct Imaging towards plants which are
in the processor forming so things which
have just formed the planets still got
all of its primordial heat embedded
within it and it's glowing we can see
those quite easily but for the planets
more like the Earth of course they've
cooled down and so we can't see that the
light is pitiful compared to a newly
formed planet we would like to get there
with direct Imaging that's the dream is
to have the Pale Blue Dart natural
photograph of it maybe even just a one
pixel photograph of it but for now the
entire solar system is one pixel with a
certainly with the transit method most
of the telescopes and so all you can do
is see where that one pixel which
contains potentially dozens of planets
and the star maybe even multiple Stars
dims for a short amount of time it dims
just a little bit and from that you're
gonna throw something yeah I mean it's
it's like being a detective in the scene
right it's very it's indirect clues of
the existence of the planet it's amazing
that humans can do that we're just
looking out in these immense distances
and looking you know if there's alien
civilizations out there like let's say
one exactly like our own
or like
would we even be able to see an earth
that passes
in the way of its sun and slightly dims
and that's the only sign we have of that
of that alien human-like civilization
out there is it's a little bit of a
dimming yeah I mean it depends on the
type of style we're talking about if it
is a star truly like the sun the dip
that causes is 84 parts per million I
mean that's just it's like the same as a
um it's like a firefly flying in front
of like a giant floodlight at a stadium
or something that's the kind of the
brightness contrast that you're trying
to compare to so it's it's extremely
difficult detection
and in the very very best cases we can
get down to that but as I said we don't
really have any true Earth analogs that
have been in the exoplank Canada yet
unless you relax that definition you say
it's not just doesn't have to be a star
just like the sun it could be a star
that's smaller than the sun it could be
these orange dwarfs or even the red
dwarf stars and the fact those stars are
smaller means that for the same size
Planet passing in front of it more light
is blocked out and so a very exciting
system for example is trappist-1 which
has seven planets which are smaller than
the earth and those who are quite easily
detectable not with a space-based
telescope even from the ground and
that's just because the star is so much
smaller that the relative increase in or
decrease in brightness is enhanced
significantly because that's smaller
size so trap is one e it's a planet
which is in the right distance for
liquid water
and it has a slightly smaller size on
the earth
um it's about 90 the size of the Earth
about 80 the mass and it's one of the
top targets right now for potentially
having life
um and yet it raises many questions
about
um what would that environment be like
this is a star which is 1 8 the mass of
the sun it's
um stars like that take a long time to
come off that adolescence when stars
first form like the sun it takes them
maybe 10 100 million years to sort of
settle into that main sequence lifetime
but for stars like these late M dwarfs
as we call them they can take up to a
billion years or more to calm down and
during that period they're producing
huge amounts of x-rays ultraviolet
radiation that could potentially rip off
the entire atmosphere it may desiccate
the plants in the system and so even if
water arrived by comets or something it
may have lost all that water due to this
prolonged period of high activity so we
have lots of of open-ended questions
about these M dwarf planets but they are
the most accessible and so in the near
term if we detect anything in terms of
buyer signatures it's going to be for
one of these red dwarf stars it's not
going to be a true Earth twin as we
would recognize it as having a yellow
star